so let's have a look at what rules
change from
today so pubs restaurants hospitality
venues will be able to reopen for
outdoor service with no curfew and no
requirement for a substantial meal
to be served with alcohol holidays and
overnight stays in england will be
allowed with the same household
but the government has told people to
minimize domestic travel where they can
self-contained holiday accommodation
like campsites
can welcome guests back non-essential
retail hairdressers
nail salons can open their doors as well
and indoor leisure facilities like gyms
and spas can reopen
but not saunas or steam rooms